hello hello hello
all right
hello everybody
kyrie now
what are you doing i'll jump on here
that's my cat
hello woodan
infinity shades what's up
akkad marvel fan
jaden blaze
janice for now what is up everybody
are we ready for zombies
i'm ready for zombies i think this is
gonna be a really cool episode
hello hello hello
oh scott mcdonald lockdown does suck yes
my mic is a little too close
well full of everybody
it is zombie this time
mr anderson
so i have to ask
what is with my mic why is it so
sensitive
but mike is like really sensitive today
okay what did everybody think of shang
ji
that's what i want to know
yeah john the animator i think this i
think we're in for like a really good
treat this time
i think uh
oh i think this is going to be a pretty
good one
last one was really good and you want to
think that they are
going to get better obviously as they go
right so i mean
yeah for those who are asking when it's
going to release
probably like 20 minutes i would say
11 out of ten for shang chi from mr
anderson yeah i
i loved it
i loved it
yeah blue mooner what is going on with
this thing
yeah the fight scenes were beautiful
yeah i uh i really
man i really love shaun ching
ah infinity shade sorry
sorry
um
man
yeah
there's nothing you can really do about
that you know
but hey yo
it'll be on disney plus in a little bit
and you'll be able to see it then thanks
for super chat but
yeah i feel here man i feel for you it's
uh
now it can't be fun that can't be fun um
for those asking about spider-man and
doctor strange like spider-man is doctor
strange so from what we know it's going
to be
spider
man zombie hunter
um
and i i
i don't know if it's this episode i
think it is because it's the zombies
episode unless there's more than one
so
i'm hoping it is hoping it is
yeah i i feel for everybody waiting for
uh shangchi to come on disney blast
uh
sorry for everybody
um am i ready for venom too heck yeah
i'm ready for venom too would on how's
it going doc was a hero and spider-man
to sacrifice himself yeah um
thank you for that super chat you know
he was
but he still died
so i'm wondering you know what i believe
is gonna happen is
um they're going to be taken like right
before they die and
when
doctor strange tells them pretty much
like hey you have to go
we're going to send you back they're
going to be like no i we die you can't
send us back because
i'm gonna die so it's like
i think that's gonna kind of be the
the plot of the of the movie and that's
why they're bad and they're just gonna
make this world their own world and you
know
no it hasn't come out yet
i'd say we probably got another
15 minutes
they usually drop it like
i'd say 10 minutes before
it's not out yet
i'm not going to spell chiang chi
i would never spoil chunky
i uh
sorry i love that movie hey what's up
kratos what's up mark thomas hello hello
woof
uh gerald prak fantastic forecast oof
you know i haven't heard anything about
that in a bit so
hey karchefam how's it going
yeah i i think he would i think uh
i think he did a really good job
with his movie um i think
i think it could have been marketed
better um
i don't think it was his fault the movie
didn't do like really really really well
i i think it would be good and thank you
for that super chat i greatly appreciate
it yeah i i i'm
i i would be fine with that yeah for
sure
uh i'm sorry liam's animation world
sorry you're sick i'm i'm kind of sick
right now too so
if uh if tonight's a short stream please
forgive me
so
uh
i i'm not watching it it's it's not yet
i'm waiting
for it to come out for everybody asking
how i watched it already
hey sam beste
you think strange supreme is in no way
home oh
um
you know i had that thought and i think
a lot of other people had that thought i
think i i saw like a bunch of videos on
that
uh it does seem like it right it does
seem like there's a hint of strange
supreme
in that trailer strange that we saw and
everybody's asking you like what's up
with him what's up with him it's
mephisto it's somebody else maybe it's
just he is becoming strange supreme
um
because you gotta remember like
doctor strange's is a pretty arrogant
guy right remember the doctor that he
was before like
that you know that's kind of how he is
and uh
i mean even even
even in infinity war you can tell right
um
he doesn't get that much
screen time and end game obviously for
him to be sarcastic in woody and et
cetera but uh i you know i think we're
just seeing more i think he's just
getting more comfortable as
that role as you know they haven't
actually called him the sorcerer supreme
in the mcu yet so i'm like is he the
sorcerer supreme
not sure about that
um only because i haven't heard it yet
but you know you might just be getting
comfortable as that roll
video shades another super chat thanks
so much
hey just want to say thanks for watching
cambridge dude really
man you've been around for a while
uh
well i appreciate that man it's uh
people like you that
help me do what i do i'm i
i can't complain
about this job because
i mean everybody's awesome i got to turn
something i did for hobby
into you know my career which is amazing
but sometimes it's really hard
because people are very critical
sometimes but uh you know comments like
this really really helped me get through
i think about you know people like you
actually do appreciate the work and it
keeps me going so thank you i super
super appreciate that thank you so much
uh as far as i know episode
is
as far as i know today's episode is
party thor i know they they came out
with the trailer today that it is the
zombie episode um
i'm not sure if party thor was supposed
to be today i was thinking that was one
of the later episodes like one of the
last episodes i do think like the final
episode is going to be like a
multiversal war type of episode and i
think we're going to see some of the
characters kind of combine with each
other which i think would be really cool
um
uh
naruto
kumar yeah
naruto
yeah
but uh
i think tom holland's voicing him
um what will this one be called
what if the avengers were zombies maybe
something like that what if
what if
i'm gonna go with that i'm gonna say
what if the avengers were zombies that's
my guess what what since we know it's
zombies what isn't everybody guess in
the comments what they think the episode
is gonna be called
guys for everybody asking if i'm gonna
spoil shangchi
uh i'm not gonna
it's one of my favorite movies like ever
like i i've seen it four times
now and it doesn't get it doesn't get
old um
tom or andrew
well
my answer is is toby but if i had to
choose between tom and andrew i would
choose tom
when is
uh
when is this like this set as in like
like
what if for shangchi
i don't know the answer to either
i know shang chi is like
it's after the blip after the snap and
everything like that um
but i don't
i don't know when i actually like my
third and fourth time watching it i was
like trying to listen to where should
listen if they said
um
what when it took place they actually
don't king varan also knows gi joe love
that name thanks for that super chat
uh those rings belong to kang left
artifacts that would be super cool
i would like it all to tie in together
like that
um
and yes he is
super
old because he's gone back in time he's
also like from the future
um
i'm thinking there's i think i like that
theory a lot i'm thinking they're
celestial related
if
if i'm if i'm like gonna call something
i'm thinking they're celestia
hey thanks for that super chat infinity
i'm gonna do some marvel fanfiction
trying to look like star wars steer but
marvel let's watch that you know i
dabbled
i dabbled with that idea um
and i and i questioned if people would
watch some marvel fanfic but you know
what that might be something i have to
do because i'll tell you what i've
written some marvel fanfict
i've written some marvel what ifs too
like uh
like i have a killer idea
for
an eternals post credit scene i won't
say it now i won't say it now because i
might actually do it and
into some
some fanfic
um
yeah maybe that's something i do maybe
that's
maybe maybe that's something what do you
think guys would you like some marvel
fanfic some stories
maybe we can even do it uh
um
maybe we can even do it to where like
people can send their fanfic in and if
someone's like really really good
maybe we can
maybe we can
throw some on the channel i want to do i
want to do
i want to figure out ways to do stuff
with you guys
it's just really hard because i tried to
do it before
and um
people took advantage people
like
i want to bring people in on like live
streams but i've done that before
where it's like a zoom and you i let
people in and it's like people will
troll
and it's like it does it's not fun right
it's like i have to kick people out and
they come in and they yell and all the
stuff and it's like some of them
are inappropriate and it's just like i
can't risk like somebody being naked on
z assume you know what i mean like just
to troll and stuff like that so it'd be
cool to find like another way to like
interact with you guys like
and like get you more involved like with
the content that's that's uh you know
going on so
um
i
wanna i wanna try something it's like
you know i really did try before i did
like theory thursdays and then we would
do like the live zoom thing and it just
theory thursdays was uh
it was fun and i loved reading all the
theories
but then
the problem was like it's really weird
like with uh um
copyright stuff
youtube's like kind of weird when it
comes to copyright stuff as in like
almost
like you don't really have to be anybody
to like copyright somebody you can file
a claim
with
youtube and they'll copyright it you
have to dispute it so when i did theory
thursday i would get theories from
people
and i would like let's just say i got a
theory from john and i would talk about
that theory but hey john posted this
theory but then you have james over here
that's like hey i sent you that theory
but you didn't give me credit for it and
then he'll try to like copyright that
and i'm like well you might have had the
same theory but i definitely didn't like
you know like discredit you
like this guy literally had like the
same theory
but it got really messy like that which
is why i stopped doing it because it
just it ultimately wasn't worth the
hassle that i had to deal with all the
time and some people would send me hey
like oh you didn't pick my theory and
i've submitted like a theory like for
like two months now and it's like okay
i'm sorry hundreds of people thousands
of people sometimes are submitting their
theories you know i can only talk about
like four in a video so
hopefully we can hopefully we can figure
something out
a video about where the rings might have
come from yeah you know i kind of talked
about it and thank for that super chat i
kind of talked about it in my post
credits scene um
breakdown
and and
if you if you want to watch it
uh
if you want to watch it go
watch that it's i think it's literally
called like let me take a look right
here
i think it's literally called chiang chi
post credit scene breakdown
uh shang chi post credit scenes
explained
um and i'm not gonna talk about it
because some people haven't seen it
but if you want to kind of know my
opinion on that that's where to find it
so
uh
i hope venom three is a
is
a
whoops
i hope venom3 is uh tom
oh i just got a notification of my own
video i was like what what did i just
post that's the live notification um i
hope
spider-man's in venom three or something
i mean they just renamed their universe
to
what was it sony spider-man universe or
something like that it's a lot better
than sony picture universe of marvel
characters or sony
pictures extended universe sp umc sony
picture universe of marvel characters
yeah
uh
it's on is it out
let's do a little refresh
it's out what if zombies i saw somebody
call it i saw somebody call it yeah
somebody somebody called it somebody
said what if zombies
maybe a few people said it i saw one
specific i saw one specific person call
it all right
uh who's my favorite newest hero shanxi
because
he's super cool and i love martial arts
all right guys we're gonna start it
mr anderson's gonna get the countdown
with me he's gonna have the time we're
gonna start in five four
three
two
one
boom
karcher fam i'm gonna get with while
it's recapping i'm gonna i'm gonna
answer your question
i've heard from mikey sutton video about
hulk becoming a mortal hulk that's why
you see him in the postcard
no
about him becoming mortal hulk uh
i don't know
um i think mikey told me that a while
ago too so it could be true um
let's avoid spoilers
um if we guess why i was like
let's avoid uh let's avoid spoilers
black would epistles versus
i think sean chi wins
all right here we go
how's this gonna start
i gotta crack open some energy or i'm
gonna fall asleep
some g fuel
you can use code cosmic if you order g
fuel online if you guys like energy
drinks
wait how long is this episode
32 minute episode
are we gonna get spider hunter
spider-man zombie hunter
i wonder if they'll call him spider
hunter we're still just going through
the openings right now guys
what if all right here we go what are we
doing
i think it's gonna start out with that
scene that mark ruffalo put on twitter
today
oh
oh
so he falls into the sanctum
during infinity war
but no one's there interesting
oh there's the cloak
oh and that's gonna go to spider-man
okay yeah totally
was i too late oh everything's like
abandoned and stuff oh here we go yeah
this is the scene that we saw this
morning on twitter
time to go green big guy
come on come on
bam
look at that
and this is
oh yeah they're eating them i could see
i could see
that seems like an overkill
oh it's gonna be coming it's gonna
become it's gonna be coming
oh
oh and there's a strange
and there's a wall
oh oh under oh nice
nice
it's actually pretty cool
don't eat me
oh the cloak's holding
that
oh
holy crap all right
oh
zombie ebony ma uh zombie ebony ma is
not good he is he has telekinetic powers
oh my gosh
what is happening
bugs bugs
oh
look at that
oh yes yeah
there he is
spider-man
oh and the cloak is following that's
pretty sweet
hey the watcher
oh this is in the quantum realm
oh snap
she got a quantum virus
oh
and so they were the zombies were smart
enough to come back
oh no i got scott
seriously hank
it was the avengers heroism that sealed
their fate
oh ant-man
oh no
iron man you can fly why weren't you
flying
so you want to survive the zombie
apocalypse
i'm not single i'm saving myself for
happy hogan
resident weirdo
that's funny
hey hey hey
luckily silent but deadly barnes
hey look who it is
oh and look who else it is
oh snap look at that
spider-man kind of built them up in a
bunch of webs
camp lehigh in new jersey
that's fun
personal chauffeur holy crap that's a
huge is it ant-man's huge
oh no they were tiny
that's funny
i know i feel like tom holland himself
should have a youtube channel right
that's hilarious
hey these guys
i bet you zombies show up
oh that was zombie falcon it looked like
giant slingshot spider-man can help you
out there
happy white
oh he's got an iron man like gauntlet
that's so cool
oh
oh
we lost happy
oh
who the heck is killing oh hawkeye
oh
oh and a zombie falcon how are they
flying and shooting bow and arrows these
are the smartest zombies i've ever seen
in my life
oh that was sick
help sharon
no one's gonna help sharon at all
oh he's gotta kill sam
that's a lot more zombies
she just straight up
cut sam in half
holy crap wow
and now sharon has an iron man got one
thingy
oh no
hey the cloak came back
heck yeah cape
hopes killing them literally
yeah this
this is like uh yeah this is like uh
couldn't remember the name
get him out of there cloak
oh
that's pretty cool
a lot of blood and guts in this one yeah
we're going to camp lee hi where's look
at that
dope
yeah you dummy you should have stayed
together
it's like rule 101
is one of them bit
oh there's a zombie
oh
oh sharon's gone there's no way
oh yep she's gone
cap
oh
with the shield and everything
oof
there he is cap
dang he killed sharon
dang
how can that dude fight he's a freaking
zombie uh hope just flew in the mouth of
sharon so
oh look at that dang
cut him in half
oof
oh and now bucky has a shield
ah
i'm covered in sharon why would you take
your mask off
oof
oof
oh
geez
what we got guys oof
that brandon gaming tv that's pretty
funny
dang
why why why why would you grab why would
you grab her hand why would you grab her
hand
oh gotta walk through that
it's kind of sad
oh that's dope look at that
oh she's carrying them
oh that's cool
dang that's pretty cool
but
no
oh i don't believe they could break that
oof
what are the odds it's a trap because
that's what i've been thinking
why aren't they climbing the fence
baba yaga
papaya
hey
look who it is
is
dude
oh
oh it's scott
oh
oh
this is weird
dang bucky with the shield is sweet
oh
you won't find what you're looking for
what's he gonna find
luck [ __ ] ruffy thank you appreciate
that what's up rana
oh vision ain't good oh that's not good
oh who's this gonna be
oh
oh no
who is that oh it's the scarlet witch oh
boy
uh
wow
he loves her
you have awakened her
[Music]
and she hasn't eaten in days
it's literally bubba yeaga
oh
bubba yuck oh no
yo that's yeah
shooting her is gonna work
hey
hey that's cool
oh
oh my gosh
did he legit just say harry potter spell
oh snap
oof
oh
oh
oh
that is
wasn't it didn't solve anything vision
oh
oh no is she gonna
oh snap
oh
run run run run
you think
you really think that was gonna work out
bucky oh
i know how many times to go oh no oh no
oh that's so cool
i know
i'm tired of watching vision
oof avenge
us okay big guy here we go
wouldn't it be kind of cool
come on hulk
[Music]
there we go
are we gonna get a zombie hulk
oh because that would be oh
or hulk for a scarlet witch that's
pretty legit
oh
[Music]
oh no
i low key one a zombie hulk
all right so
i really want a zombie oh
do we get that because that's that's
what i want now
huh
118
huh
so do we think
is that it
oh
no
oh
oh oh oh no
oh
what
oh that's a cool little ending
okay okay
wow okay
wait no go back i want to see who all
the voices were
show me all the voices please
wow
wow okay so i think technically that
might have been chadwick's last
maybe we'll see him again
interesting that wasn't tom holland
that was hudson thames
i guess tom holland was
filming uncharted and filming
no way home i guess why he couldn't do
it
and then it wasn't
chris evans
interesting
oh that's uh that's what is that two
times now we got or i guess
let's just say is that two times that we
got the end of the universe but i guess
technically the second one where
t'challa was star-lord
ended
with you know ego popping up
and them being like yeah he goes pretty
much gonna destroy the universe now
huh all right what are we writing it
everybody put it in the comments down
below
what do we rate in this episode
oh hi christopher
i don't hear you
i don't hear christopher
let me see if my settings are messed up
settings
where's audio
voice and video yeah that works
output
i hear him now
can you
can you hear me
you're the
guy from fortnite
billions and millions did you just say
billions
billions and millions okay
okay okay
okay okay
uh i'm currently
well i'm currently trying to pull you up
on the screen hold on
i'm currently
getting every getting everybody else's
ratings of the episode
and uh
it seems pretty mixed
d
mickey a hundred out of ten
um
there's a six out of ten nine out of ten
a 69
um
eight out of ten eight out of ten nine
out of ten ten six of ten
six six nine
one tony wick a one
three point five
eleven
it
it did feel a little
it was rushed it was definitely rushed
next week
i didn't mind
it wasn't tom holland
yeah it was like everybody but tom
holland and chris evans
came
i uh
i'm i'm still trying to figure out how i
felt about that episode to be perfectly
honest um
i don't know i thought about it i
genuinely don't know how i felt about it
i think it was cool i think it was a
cool idea
um i definitely enjoyed it
i i think it oh they can't hear you
thanks tnt shooter i mean it was
revolutionary what he was saying you
should have heard it i know never before
has anything that i would do
everyone would go i would have put every
other um right now to cosmic culture he
would get all my followers right
unfortunately
yeah unfortunately we can't uh he can't
repeat it because it's too sacred so
there you go
um i
okay there are cool things they're okay
they're definitely cool things hit me
with the highlights tell me what the
highlights uh hulk versus scarlet witch
that was lit that was cool i
maybe i'm a little let down because i
really wanted zombie hulk
i thought yeah that would have been that
was part of the rushed ending right
because i feel like ultimately he would
have turned into a zombie i don't know
like i guess
they had like a 30 like all episodes
have been like 32 minutes long like
right around there might give or take
this 27
now i was like 32. most of 32. they
might have ended at 27 you know because
credits yeah it felt short
it didn't feel long enough
i didn't check if it was post credit i
figured i didn't either i figured there
was yeah we probably should
um i figured
you let me do it i figured there wasn't
a post credit
but let's uh
let's just double check here
how did you feel about i was getting
some people commenting that they weren't
necessarily happy watching in the heroes
get murdered even though they were
zombies did you care about that it's
animation i thought it was i i don't
care but i like that stuff yeah i
personally don't
um
it'd be one thing if they died and like
that was it like they're actually dead
like
in the emcee and everything
that would be a different thing um
that would be totally different but
that's not how it is
i and that's
the big problem with what if isn't it
there's no repercussions to anything
yeah and you can say it connects all you
want and it does
but but when it exists in other
universes
one when it exists in other universes
and two when it exists in other
universes that end up getting destroyed
i mean it'd be cool if in doctor strange
on the multiverse of madness they have
to travel to this universe the zombie
one for some reason and we pick up right
where they left off in the aftermath of
it but i just don't see how that would
fit into the movie no i don't think it
would make sense that much exactly but
that would be cool if they were to do
something like that but they're not i
don't think they are
yeah
um
but yeah the ending is the reason why
this is not my favorite episode i loved
the whole the beginning was fun
spider-man was fun the character
matchmaking here was kind of fun you
know what shows up with spider-man and
bucky and i really liked that like
i really liked happy bam bam
[Laughter]
that was pretty good i enjoyed that
um
yeah i just i i
i liked it i think the ending could have
been better
i think it was a good episode
it seemed rushed at the end towards the
end uh but it was voicing tom holland it
sounded who was voicing spider-man it
sounded like tom holland
no it wasn't 100 wasn't it was some dude
i didn't i didn't i don't remember who
it was but it wasn't tom
i looked the two people who didn't
reprise their roles were chris evans as
captain america which like
oh i guess he had a line in the
beginning
um yeah also rookie moved by iron man he
could yeah what the heck lie and the
dude stood on the ground iron suit and
he has an iron suit that's like has
taken bullets and
yeah everything he's penetrating your
iron suit just living it yeah what's
that about like you're gonna tell me
happy couldn't i guess maybe it might
have fit happy i was gonna say find an
iron man suit might not fit him yeah
cause he doesn't have the brains to talk
okay let's also talk about how these
were the smartest zombies in the history
of anything done with zombies right i
mean hawkeye shooting arrows falcons
with the falcons flying with his wings
he got cutting back that's insane iron
man had intense right
doctor zombie doctor strange
walking out there doing portals got
decapitated
it was very like interesting it was very
entertaining it was a lot of fun it's
just the ending really blew it for me
i mean i wanted to see wakanda i want to
see them fight thanos i want there's
give me a part two
no i think i mean they they basically
tell you like what i mean thanos had
five infinity stones
yeah i would love this but he's a zombie
but then like you were saying they all
have like the intelligence of the
superhero he had five infinity stones
they were done
they were done
and then they take they take the
they take the stuff from okay right but
like
disappointed but vision says he has to
atone for what he did
and then he just killed himself right
yeah like super weird
i can't leave her
but here's my mind stone and i'm like
what
uh
and i'm just like i was
you didn't you could have like at least
i get it like he loves her he can't
fight her
but for extremely logical intellectual
synthesized i feel like
i feel like he
i mean it's all part of the fun story
right it's the love story between him
and i know what and yeah i would have i
would have liked i love how people in my
chat were like how many times we got to
watch vision die
they talked about ben
they did they mentioned ben parker
that's sad uncle ben
yeah and chadwick uh
chadwick i didn't actually expect to see
chadwick yeah yeah especially especially
the line
we thought you were dead it got me i was
like oh gotcha hey marina
always coming in every week super
appreciate that thank you for that super
chat am i a patreon no
um
not yet so i have decided over the past
couple weeks that i am gonna do patreon
i will have exclusive content on there
and my main thing about patreon is is
because i was gonna i still am gonna do
channel memberships on youtube but i'm
just gonna do like one tier and that's
gonna be for like stickers and stuff and
badges and stuff if you guys want them
because i know some people have been
asking for like stickers and stuff so
it's gonna be like 99 cent tier and you
get any sticker i could possibly give
you i think it's like five
uh but i'm gonna do patreon i'll do
exclusive content on there and it's so i
have a backup in case
fingers crossed youtube something never
happens youtube one day so you know if
youtube comes crashing down for whatever
reason i'll have patreon as back up to
where i will still have somewhat of a
job left um
i i appreciate you checking out that
link uh i thought the link still worked
i'll have to check on that thank you
thank you for that chat um
dj wavy d what's up thanks for super
chat maybe this time thor will aim for
the head
uh
well we didn't
i guess thor is not on earth huh thor is
yeah thor had a bottle i think thanos
will probably get all the infinity
stones before thor shows up
and then infect the universe
yeah that's the question what does what
does a thanos
what does a zombie thanos snap for
turn everybody into turn everybody with
zombies oh he can eat them
because a zombie doesn't want to turn
other people into zombies they want to
eat them
right
what would a zombie eat if everybody was
zombies exactly so that would be
unhelpful to thanos he'd be starved
um
i was gonna say something and now i've
forgotten yeah we'll never know that's
what the answer is we'll never get the
answer that what if question warren they
left us on a cliffhanger right this is
gonna be an interesting breakdown
because
there's not much to break down i mean
obviously
there's obviously all the links and
everything and stuff like that
but uh
it's gonna be an interesting one
ah
full transparency
i haven't read the marvel zombie comics
zombies aren't really my thing
like north horror right you could ask
anybody who knows me i don't like scary
things
i don't watch horror movies
i don't watch even remotely close to
scary movies um
uh
i don't like i i like uh like zombieland
and stuff like that but i feel like i'm
kind of burnt out with zombies like
world war z was good
uh
what was the will smith i am legend was
good and the zombieland ones are good
and i feel like i'm like kind of burnt
out although this was a lot of fun
watching this one but i'll do scary
horror stuff i don't go to like haunted
houses and halloween horror nights and
all that stuff like that uh crystals all
that stuff
so uh
i i haven't read marvel
zombies
full transparencies a lot of red but but
not bad um
yeah i just i've never been that
entertained by the idea of zombies
um but i do think this was a cool
episode i and you know people like what
they like i'm not crapping on anybody
like zombies uh
so yeah i'm gonna watch that exchange
too of course i'm gonna watch doctor
strange too and like i've watched scary
movies like with you know like if i have
a date or something like i'm dating a
girl and she's like let's watch this i'm
like okay like try not to seem like a
whip
but literally i'm like i did get some
serious zombieland vibes from the
beginning i did too yeah yeah yeah i did
too your guide to staying alive from
peter parker that was pretty cool
that was pretty cool that was pretty
cool man i'm getting uh
i'm getting a lot of mixed signals here
with everybody
somebody some people yeah i think some
people really were about that and some
people were like yeah that's not my
thing
yeah and that's you know that's fine
that's fine um i would expect that from
an episode like this it really is kind
of left field um
something somebody would have to like be
very interested in definitely seemed
like there was a lot of high
anticipation and excitement for it uh
but then there's probably people who are
like yeah i'm better off seeing my
captain america my iron man in normal
mode not inside
yeah right uh that i can see how that i
i can see how that could strike a chord
with some people uh wait wait wait we
gotta talk about ant man
i hate that
you didn't like that you know i hate
stuff like that
it wasn't like that he wasn't a robot he
was ahead he was just ahead alive i
hated him yeah but it was great i
actually really liked how the cloak was
like his body
yeah i thought it was hilarious
i used dad jokes as a coping mechanism
yeah right
i don't know he cracked me up i thought
that was a lot of fun it was like an aj
yeah if aj were in the mcu he would be
scott lang's head it's funny because i
was wondering who that was when we saw
him in the trailer
like i because like it's with an
animated can't really make it right you
can't make it out and then i was like oh
it's scott that's something
that's cracked me up it corrects me yeah
venom i do not think it's gonna be
annoying
um
no i like halloween when it's like hey
let's dress up as like superheroes and
stuff
i love spooky stuff and and not when
it's like hey
let's go to haunted houses and stuff
like that oh i would i would never never
do that yeah
for the last 10 years chris is really
big in that stuff him and him and his
wife are really big into that spooky
season has officially begun ladies and
gentlemen
big fan but uh no it's fun and i and
again it brings us back the same thing
we talk about with this every week is
you know that's what what if's for you
know um
it's for these kind of crazy scenarios
that i don't think will ever actually be
brought up in the mcu necessarily like
they're like you know what we're
probably not gonna do live-action
zombies but it's there and people like
it let's make a what-if out of it you
know
yeah yeah hey
drew batista thanks for super chat says
the head in a jar was a hint to zombie
hope's head in a jar and t'challa was
used to feed ant-man in the comics
interesting the comics he escaped
missing a leg okay there you go
oh well there you go well thanks for
that
that'll be useful that'll definitely be
useful yeah
what did i rate the episode i would give
it a either 7.5 or eight it's not my
favorite episode it's my second favorite
episode my favorite is still the second
episode i mean quite honestly it was a
good
episode the ending just threw me off
because it felt super rushed and
incomplete it's really like it's the
biggest thing is like it's incomplete to
me
which is very unsatisfying
yeah that's
that's the big
that's that's like one of the worst
things when it comes to like
uh
like film making and and like writing
where it's like when you're given like
hey this has to be this long and you're
like well we have so much good content
like within this
you know 32 minutes 27 minutes you know
if you take out the credits like
what do i cut like
right the ending
yeah right well you know we were just
gonna show them flying in and then
thanos is gonna like you could just cut
that and say the universe gets destroyed
and it's just kind of like i can see how
they came to that conclusion but to me
it just felt a little
incomplete
what was the saddest part to me and
warren i don't know i didn't really feel
sad about anything i didn't mind
watching cap die or falcon die or any of
that it's not real to me
spider-man's little crush on hope was
kind of cute though seeing him lose hope
was was a little sad
i mean that would have that would have
had to have been the hardest or the
saddest yeah that's
but again to me it's not real
no
the emotion was there no don't get me
wrong i didn't feel like the emotion i
actually felt like
it was pretty sad
the hope part especially how she carried
them all across and i was just like oh
that sucks
yeah episode two in the strange one
we're more complete you're completely
right right ryan
yeah maybe they will make a part two
omar who knows i hope so that'd be nice
yeah i feel like there's something there
you know
okay now thanos is here and he's a
zombie
you have to wonder how he
got eaten by a zombie with five infinity
stones feel like he could have done
something about that
and his skin is like the thickest skin
iron
barely
iron man barely made him bleed and he
tossed like a
iron man like shoved part of the planet
into them with the rocks and everything
and
they're telling me some zombies teeth
pierced nebula crashed a ship into him
and he was fine
i'm calling bs on that one maybe in this
universe
what's with these zombies they're like
the greatest smartest strongest zombies
you've ever seen avengers are more
efficient as the zombies than they were
at the avengers i mean seriously oh my
gosh again iron man full armor suit
yeah takes monkey bullets
and and
and you got infected something dicks a
lot what about blaming hank pym again
dude hank pym freaking
avengers
and then and then kills him again right
it's you know
the ultimate bad guy it looks like can
we who can we make f up this universe oh
hank yeah he's in the background doing
who knows what let's blame hank again
yeah
yeah oh
well it was a fun episode it was fun
episode it was cool to watch like fun i
like that they actually killed a lot of
them i actually like that like
when when uh
when happy got like
when the thing went through him i was
like oh
and then he got pulled back man
yeah i was like oh yeah but i was like
oh snap that like that's like that's
like through him like
and then there's hawkeye chilling and
i'm like
okay
yeah there were some pretty fun scenes
in there and that's just something fun
you can get an animation that it doesn't
look ridiculous it's not all gory and
stuff because it's like yeah you get it
that is something that i do actually
like about this like it's it you can do
a lot with it the animation you can make
it like gory and it's not gory because
it's animation right right
what other episodes do we have
there's more right
so party thor what else the ending one
the ultron yeah
the ultron
one well
yeah i don't think it's gonna be so much
vision i think it's just gonna more be
like hey let's build i'll try and they
build ultron because the scene
like i think it was this the scene that
we thought was like vision
it was like we thought it was ultron
ripping the mindset out of vision was
just in this episode where it was just
vision right ripping it out of himself
okay so those two do we know of any
other one
slash have we seen any zombie scenes in
any trailers that didn't show up in this
episode
that's what i'm trying to map out as if
there's room for a top part too no hey
show a lot of zombie footage it was
mostly just captain america in the
trains
thanks for the super chat drew what you
said sorry guys it's like 2 a.m for me
i'm very tired um
janet's head in the jar
oh yeah yeah yeah no i think i i picked
that up yeah janet's head in the jar in
the uh
in the comics
uh
when happy was like blam blam blam i was
pleased and then i thought don't let him
die then he died
[Music]
i actually really enjoyed that oh the
gamora one the avengers one that's
another one
yeah
but
but is that part of the last one
i don't know oh the killmonger and iron
man one that's one thank you teague
[Music]
so if those each are separate ones then
there won't be a part two but if the
gamora one is part of the last one there
is room for a part two i don't think
we're gonna part two zombies i wanna
part two well
the watcher said the end of the universe
so
stupid watch it what's he think he knows
everything uh yeah
he's totally going to go into the main
mcu when i asked jeffrey right
i don't know if i did i post that on
youtube
no i don't think so i didn't edit it
but i think i was in brazil sorry i
don't know no i
so guys in the in the what if press
conference i actually spoke to jeffrey
right
and i i asked him
what the chances are of his character
the watcher coming into the mcu and he
really stepped around the question
uh
and he said you know anything's possible
and then he said you know
what if it's literally like what he said
he said i'll leave you with this you
know what if and i was like ha you're
gonna be in the real mcu
as i think he should uh especially if
they're saying that this you know all
this stuff actually does connect in the
mcu then
then he
maybe he's the biggest connection out of
everything
like yeah he's watching these animated
ones but if this is cannon to the mcu
then he's technically watching over all
the other ones as well he's there
yeah so boom i just figured i mean yeah
right if he watches all the multiverses
then he's watching ours there's no
reason why he doesn't watch our timeline
right especially since they said it's
canon so if there comes a time we need
the watcher it will be this watcher 100
it'll be jeffrey right but i hope like i
hope it's him
like i hope they like kind of shape his
head and everything in him yeah
yeah um so about the nine episodes thing
you know when i was in the press
conference i talked to brad wonderbomb
who was the executive
uh producer on this one he said ten but
then i heard like something happen and
then they they like got rid of one or
something like that well did scarlett
have an episode
because she was supposed to be in it
wasn't she i mean she's on the big board
isn't there like a
and they got rid of it there's like a
pot isn't there like an apocalypse
there was supposed to be like an
apocalypse black widow i think
yeah and i think they got rid of it
because of the whole scarlet jansen
thing i believe so ah
and i feel like they try to do a really
hush in another raid i like that we
talked about it
well i didn't even really hear about it
except for like no all of a sudden it
was just like yeah there's only nine
like they haven't actually announced
that they were gonna be nine yeah but
there were going to be 10 for sure
yeah uh sn
and i hope i pronounced that right
that's the big question how did zam
thanos thanos how did thanos turn into a
zombie i'm sitting here thanos iron man
trying to think who else shouldn't have
yet
i'm sitting here going
thanos skin is impenetrable
i mean
impenetrable
all that for a drop of blood you're
telling me a zombie bit him
they're freaking genki teeth
maybe like maybe like
maybe like a a tiger got infected in bed
they're like a zombie tiger bit through
his skin with his fangs
zombie hulk got him right well
that's not possible we know that
but uh
oh that's a good question too
dragon priest nine why did thanos go to
wakanda
because he originally goes that's where
the stone was no he originally goes
there for the mine stone
but vision wasn't
but vision wasn't there
no but they had it they took it to
wakanda
yeah but thanos was clearly there way
before
was he yeah he was waiting for them when
they got in he could have been a cut
scene no he was waiting for them they
got in there oh well i don't know then
yeah that's weird the ending was rushed
it wasn't good i don't expect it to make
sense just be honest about that it was a
trash ending
probably the worst ending of what if so
far actually
yeah
just disappointing so okay but like epis
so three had a cliff cliffhanger
captain marvel showed up
and loki took over the world
so they just gonna go back to that in
season two
well they're all different universes
right they just skip over them and start
a new one i guess
hank or janet could have been thanos
from the inside back to the ant-man up
thanos well we kind of saw that because
she went up sharon
and he did go up and sharon granted
sharon doesn't have supposed
impenetrable skin since stenoscopic by
zombie um
i kept sharing on me like
yeah
yeah that was a little morbid yeah
bucky just kind of shoves her off to the
side
yeah
literally it was like
wait a second bucky didn't technically
die
he just got thrown i mean really yeah i
guess he could have a super
yeah yeah yeah yeah bucky was alive he's
a super soldier
yeah
he think he eated though he got eated
hard yeah i eat it but no he's not that
you're accurate
you eat the [ __ ] i eat
yeah
i
what is the next marvel series i believe
it's hawkeye it's hawkeye yeah
miss marvel
i think that then as far as disney plus
shows go
that's the one i'm most excited for
coming up although
i mean i'm excited for all of them but i
think that ranks at the top miss
tomorrow's gonna be interesting um
i'm curious to see what they like
introduce in miss marvel like are we
doing inhumans are we doing some type of
mutants like
hope they start introducing some mutant
stuff soon yeah introduction of the the
the young avengers with her
uh i think it's been confirmed captain
marvel is going to be in the show it's
like all right what is going on here i'm
really looking forward to secret
invasion too that's going to be
oh yeah that's going to be
that's gonna be a big one my girl emilia
clarke yeah yeah that's gonna be that's
gonna be a big one secret invasion's
gonna gonna start i think like some big
stuff some big stuff but i mean each
each show has something the to very much
look forward to hawkeye has mohawk and
the introduction of kate bishop
i'll call the now inclusion of valentina
which is pretty exciting that too that
too
oh yeah yeah yeah yelena biloba's gonna
yeah
jack and stuff up there which i'm really
that definitely amped up the excitement
for hawkeye which i think they knew yeah
for sure what they were doing with that
for sure uh she hulk or miss marvel we
just talked about that it's gonna have a
lot of
stuff hi jim bo daddy thank you for
joining
uh she-hulk we're gonna get a new hulk
and the other hulk's gonna be in it and
uh
and i don't think he's going anywhere i
don't think he's passing his mantle just
yet maybe he is but he seems like mark
ruffalo wants to be held till he dies
yeah i'm avoiding talking about
something specific for spoilers but yeah
um
it looks like it's getting old though um
thank you so you
wwe
appreciate that uh can i show you
stormbreaker yeah
yeah let me grab it
what was our opinion on the song i'm
going to white chris
you're still here but your picture's
gone yeah this is storm
he's showing off stormbreaker guys i
know you can't see it but it's
stormbreaker it's cool
it's heavy
i mean it's really big like
it's big
what's up kitty cat
you are a whiner cat
i'm coming back
okay
hi
datastore that is stormbreaker
oof how did wanda become a zombie she
could fly and has telekinesis and she
can make people hey
you know they don't need to
no they don't they don't the point of
the matter was she's a zombie and vision
had a human emotion and tried to save
her
yeah and i'm okay with that you know
that doesn't necessarily bug me for what
if i mean
no it doesn't it it's not the russian
doesn't need to be rushed
oh thanos was here and everything got
destroyed
was like okay like i get it
but i like would have liked a tiny bit
more elaboration
yeah
i mean it was still my second favorite
episode it just isn't my first because
of that ending i just it just wasn't it
didn't do it for me you're still
sticking with t'challa
an episode i'm still sticking with
t'challa that episode was a blast i had
a fun time watching that episode well
that's probably
i kind of look like adam devine i think
that's
like the third fourth time i've heard
that
interesting the guy from pitch perfect
and yeah i don't know
i've never seen a workout you've never
seen pitch perfect no i've never seen
you as adam divine
i think we have like the same body type
yeah they're kind of bulky bulky
not cut not
yeah
yeah what are you saying i'm a typical
white guy
typical white guy
um
basic point matthew barrow
i've heard yeah you know fisk is coming
hopefully it's enough rios
because that would be a shame if they
replaced ml man he was so good
perfect perfect
um
every reflection of what wanda did and
that's a good one lauren from torqued
community member it's almost a
reflection of what wanda did in one
division put others at risk to live her
days out with vision even though she
knew it was a big doo-doo move oh no she
totally
she totally knew
right so that's kind of a cool
reflection
it was totally a mirror shows the
strength of the relationship when we can
get white vision though i'm trying to
see some more vision i love vision
i just keep going back to what people in
my chat oh you're not on screen i just
keep going back to what people in my
chat said how many times you have to
watch vision die
i'm sure we'll watch him die again
ladies and gentlemen i mean he's a
computer program his consciousness could
be kept on a flash drive and then re
re-upload it somewhere else you know
he could just keep coming back in life
in the comics that's what makes altron
so freaking cool
you know is that he just continuously
returns because he's story he never dies
like completely in the comics and that's
exactly what we're seeing with vision
who is essentially you know a good boy
version of of ultron
in the mcu and it's like
just you could just download his
consciousness and re-upload it at any
time and any type of being that can
contain that
i think the only universe where he
couldn't technically live is this
universe because
you need somebody like stark to
to make that to bring him to like to
know where he's at right because he
exists inside of stark technologies
right right so you need like stark or
pepper
or uh peter or
something
but uh
september 9th 2045 video comes out
that's far away
no it's tomorrow
2045. oh what video is that i don't know
this is what he just said september 9th
2045 vid comes out that's freaking far
away i'll be dead by then probably
45 that's like 20 years i'll be dead by
that one that's probably true
i'll be lost i'm gonna live forever to
like 120 but i'm not going to live
you'll live but
well
i'm gonna die in a hang gliding accident
at some point and never forget that line
you can only crash so many times before
you actually eat it
hey i'm gonna go out on fire like in the
snow on fire in the snow
so here we go
uh i haven't forgotten about armor wars
aj i just uh we haven't heard well it's
far away that's why right we talked yeah
we don't have a release date or anything
right we talk about what's upcoming
right what's like really upcoming
hawkeye miss marvel confirmed
yeah i mean our awareness is confirmed
we just have no idea when it's coming
well confirmed
which i guess miss marvel doesn't
technically have hey welcome shaggy
first watch party what is up we chilling
uh
or to end
or catching marvel in the corner orchard
uh which was my favorite episode so far
last episode strange supreme
that was baller
sounds like a pizza i'll have one
strange supreme one strange supreme
please i would like it to try to murder
me and absorb myself like it to not
destroy my universe
yeah i would like it on repeat though um
i thought that episode was footnote
episode and i thought it was
emotional well we weren't talking about
emotion and what if i actually thought
it was
got it
yeah yeah
yeah
rick's fantasy says not gonna lie this
episode is pretty whacked yeah there's a
pretty quack quack there's uh
mixed
opinions on this i personally liked it
and i
i thought it was a fun ride
the ending just kind of go to the end
i'm a little bummed
yeah i think it was a cool idea and i
think that's the whole point of what if
is to do cool ideas that you can't
really
like what like like one ideas that
actually don't affect the real mcu like
yes i know it's canon to the mcu and i
know it connects but it's often separate
universes
where it doesn't matter like let's just
be honest maybe some of them matter but
like this episode doesn't matter i don't
know i don't think any of them really
matter maybe the last one
yeah maybe you'll see like a glimpse of
them in multiverse of madness maybe it
pops up like a little bit
but um
it's nice that they don't matter
you know because then you can it's nice
to have a low stakes mcu project right
everything is so high stake high energy
it matters it's important everything
affects everything you know yeah it's
just like hey you guys want to watch
thanos at a bar with with t'challa and
and you know spider-man hit on hope
while zombies are killing everybody yeah
here you go that's kind of nice there is
a nice thing about the breather yeah
you know you're gonna like some episodes
you're gonna not like some episodes
that's how i've been you know um
personally i don't have some bangers
coming yeah i i don't think there's an
episode that i didn't really like have a
good time watching
um
last episode i thoroughly enjoyed uh and
i enjoyed this one i enjoyed this
episode which was the third i forgotten
it that was when the avengers die
yeah so the first and the third were
kind of underwhelming i did not enjoy
watching them i just wasn't like wow
this is fun yeah you know like
i don't know people keep saying the
first one was underwhelming i thought
i thought the story was underwhelming
because it's the same story but i
actually thought the animation was
really good
but the animation is cool but the story
is a big part of
the experience you know yeah true
but um
by them
that's all part yeah
that's all part of it and that's you
know the ending didn't ruin the episode
for me here but it definitely
is part of the experience is the ending
and i think the strange episodes ending
was a huge
huge nice rap
and that's a huge positive you just
gotta look at it as different directions
yeah because it actually showed the
ending of it
oh wait oh the universe is
made you want more from the episode
ain't that what writers want haha i was
frustrated with it but it didn't take
away from the episode for me well that's
good take torqued
it ruined the episode for me
i'm salty chris is assaulted boy
he's high in sodium
well guys i am dead tired like and i
have a headache i can barely keep my
eyes open because these lights are just
beaming on my face right now but hey
what a great watch party tonight what a
cool episode and i actually really
enjoyed it i'm going to give it a 8 out
of 10.
i i feel like i would have given it a 9
or 10 out of 10 if it wasn't for that
if it wasn't for such a quick ending it
was like oh they're on the quinjet and
they're talking and everything's like
cool and
done
really quick and i are on the same but
by the way thanos goes and kills
everybody because he's somebody has all
hey guys if you haven't subscribed to
chris over causes culture that is chris
he does what i do he just talks about
all movies
so if you like movies in general
go give him a sub
he's actually in the room
yeah over here that room
he's a couple i'm over here guys
away
and i'm only one click away one click
away be sure to uh head over to cosmic
culture you can click that link in the
description or in the description wow
it's like i'm recording a youtube video
what did you just do to your
screen um you're in black and white now
yeah i'm
trying to switch my camera over
luckily if mr anderson's got you covered
up we lost chris okay now i'm still here
i'm still here i'm still here i'm not
good you lost your you lost it you lost
it i'm black and white though what that
i told you all right he's back anyways
uh if you enjoyed the episode awesome i
enjoyed it if you didn't well hopefully
the next one gets you uh i'm sticking
right now with episode four still my
favorite
extreme supreme i think it was
freaking awesome uh but this is a lot of
fun this is a fun ride and uh it's nice
to have something that isn't so high
stakes like you were saying chris but uh
hey thanks for everybody for showing up
super awesome live stream thank you to
mr anderson for being an awesome mod uh
he's the best thank you to everybody who
showed up and if you chatted thank you
if you super chatted thank you and if
you just hung out in the back thank you
as well that's uh what makes the live
stream super cool
and uh
yeah glad everyone could show up uh
expect a breakdown to oh chris is gone
again okay i'm still here no you're gone
nope you lost yourself i'm still here
muted
uh so i'm gonna get some rest i'm gonna
wake up do a breakdown i'm gonna think
of some cool stuff to talk about for
this one because there was a lot of cool
stuff in there um
but yeah i love you all i appreciate you
all thank you all so much